[Musique]
quoi de mieux par une journée bien
froide divers que de se retrouver autour
d'une bonne fondue
trois des journalistes à la recherche de
l'épicerie mais tu as des preuves
trois ensembles de fondue electric 3
décathlon utilisé autant pour des fondue
chinoise au fromage ou au chocolat
ce cas clancy en demande de ne pas le
réchauffé sur le gaz et son électricité
en gestion directe ici qu'il faut les
poignées sont vissés mais pas sous des
noms c'est sûr que c'est parce que plus
solide
le fonds est à ses mails c'est pas comme
un chaudron pour garder sa chaleur très
longtemps la prise électrique qui est
magnétique ceux des faits très
rapidement des quelques accroches le fil
c'est que ça décroche facilement à
l'usagé pendant ces sources écoutées si
tu avais été injustement six mois je le
fais au lieu de tirer que le saas havas
décroché automatiquement occasion m
c'est pas très élégant
c'est moins dramatique avec la flamme
alors qu'après c'est donc avec ça
merci pour ta chauffer le bouillon a pas
trop toucher ses shows où les
fourchettes accroche systématiquement
dès qu'on va les dégâts j'ai donc on
déplace le pas avec la boue sur ils se
promènent c'est pas très pratique
c'est le trudeau j'ai chauffer le
bouillon dans un autre chaudron parce
qu'ils disent qu'il faut pas chauffé
directement dans le chaudron
si bien stable ça bouge pas
sentinelles en prévention y plonge on
dit oui il maintient sa température
on vérifie les poignées on vérifie la
base et ne chauffe pas l'antique la boue
sur lequel on accroche les pochettes
c'est encombrant plus qu'autre chose bon
je l'utiliserai même pas le caquelon
lui-même est moins profond que les
autres donc est plus facile
d'utilisation mois il usa je préfère
cette hauteur que ça prend évidemment
une rallonge à ce que le fils est passé
en cuisine a pour nom
et voilà
quelle analyse ricardo 100 dollars' est
plus chère de l'échantillon davantage
c'est que tu es fait chauffer le
bouillon directement dans le chaudron le
fil d'alimentation se décolle pas avec
un système magnétique pro caisse et de
prévention des incendies
comment vraiment de passer le fil sur la
table et de mettre un meuble quelque
chose pour empêcher les gens passaient
pour éviter de s'enfarger dans le film
lui et 1200 watts
les autres font 1500 donc il est moins
puissant que les autres est ce que c'est
ça qui fait que ça prend du temps à
réchauffer je disais qu'est ce qui est
intéressant si les températures sont
automatiques selon le type de fonds du
grand tpu son bouillon saga de la bonne
température tout le monde n'a pas besoin
de gérer
normalement on va boire mais où est-il
plus grand problème ça a pris du temps
afin que le bouillon re bouillonne et
mon dieu c'est comme ça bouillait pas
jamais
[Musique]
ce modèle là c'est simple tu fais tout
dessus c'est top
tu prépares tu réchauffe du salaire de
chaudes comme c'est quand même pratique
pareil pour la fondue au fromage dans le
bain marie la température est un peu
plus et d'injuste et sans celui là il a
besoin de surveillance humaine alors que
tu as l'impression que veronica lario sa
bonne une scène tu laisses aller vite
comme la marine tu sens il n'y aura pas
de d'accidents que ça colle et c'était
noël
[Musique]
dans le choc la session veux pas qu'ils
soient trop chaud pour cette boue qui se
séparent qui cristallise dans celui ci
quand même intéressant parce qu'on a
fait fondre le chocolat à paris seront
des maris donc pas contacter directement
de richaud il reste fonderie fiche port
dans ce cas clown fait fondre le
chocolat sur la cuisinière directement
dans le caquelon pour le bouton chocolat
nom normalement t'es rien à faire j'ai
laissé textures
celui ci lui héritage a fait fondre le
chocolat directement dedans sur un
réchaud on a eu du mal à trouver la
température idéale j'imagine quand le
pratiquant plusieurs reprises tu finis
par le connaître l'appareil puisse
savoir comment ils fonctionnent au
serait la meilleure texture ce serait
celle avec le truc de musa giesbert
effectivement je trouve sa peine
différent ce deuxième temps en céramique
a permis à l'ensemble trudeau de s'est
hissé au premier rang
à l'unanimité les journalistes l'ont
choisi aussi pour sa stabilité et la
qualité de ses matériaux minimum pour
compliquer face et l'utiliser c'est là
la vie ou s'ils te produire kibo esprit
loft où ça vaut vraiment la peine